Transcriber: Haktan Can Bayram
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Pusulamızı nasıl yaratmamız
gerektiğiyle ilgili
kendi hikayemden yola çıkarak sizlere
destek olmaya çalışacağım.
Hali hazırda şu an bir özel üniversitenin
bölüm başkanlığını yürütüyorum.
Rektör danışmanıyım. MIT’nin yapay zeka
ve bilgisayar bilimleri laboratuvarının
araştırmacısıyım.
Türkiye’de henüz işlenmemiş alanlarda çok
farklı patentlerim ve projelerim var.
Aynı zamanda 2020 yılının Yapay Zeka
Alanında Farkındalık Yaratan Lider
ödülüne sahibim.
Ve tüm bunların yanında Yapay Zeka
Politikaları Derneği'nin yapay zeka
alanındaki danışmanı ve Fütüristler
Derneği’nin Başkan Yardımcısıyım.
Her biri birbirinden güzel tüm bu
unvanların arkasında kocaman bir
hayal kırıklığı, kocaman bir
başarısızlık hikayesi.
Bir kere şurada netleşelim, hayat
hiç kimseye adil değil.
Çok iyi liselerden mezun olmadım
ya da böyle bir imkanım
hiçbir zaman olmadı.
Aslında bir öğretmen anne babanın
çocuğuydum ve hayatın aslında başlarken
1-0′dan daha ziyade 10-0 yenik
başlayan çocuklarından bir tanesiydim.
Ailenizdeki sorunların sizi çok aştığı
dönemlerde bunlarla mücadele edemediğiniz,
kaçacağınız tek yer vardır.
Bunlar da kitaplardır.
Hayatım boyunca üç tane annem oldu,
çünkü annem maalesef 1999-2009
ve geçtiğimiz sene geçirdiği beyin
ameliyatları sonrasında her seferinde
karakteri bambaşka bir insan
olarak karşıma çıktı.
3 farklı anneyi idare etmek bir çocuğun
çeşitli hayat hikayesinde oldukça
kırılgan anları ifade eder.
İlk tercihi, hayattaki ilk dönüm
noktasını sanıyorum
Yıldız Teknik Üniversitesi Matematik
Bölümü'nü tercih ederken yaptım.
Bizim dönemimizde sizlerin zamanındaki
kadar şanslı değildik.
Çünkü sınav sonuçlarımızı ancak
tercihlerimiz ile beraber görebiliyorduk.
Yani tercihlerimizi yaparken kutumuzda
büyük hissedip hissetmediğimize göre
7 ya da 9 tane tercih yapacaktık.
Aslında bundan sonra hayatımı
şekillendirecek bir karar verdim.
Duygusal değil sayısal karar verip
sayısal değerlere güvenmek
ve kendime şunu sordum.
5 yıl sonrasının Türkiye’sine
ya da 5 yıl sonrasının dünyasına
baktığımda neyi yazarsam
benim daha çok işime yarar?
Neyi yazarsam gerçekten olmak
istediklerimi gerçekleştirebilir,
hayallerimin peşinden koşabilirdim?
Bu sorunun cevabını 2 temel
meslekte buldum.
Biri doktorluktu,
öteki de matematikti.
Birbirinden alakasız gibi gözüken
tercihleri sıraladım.
Hatta o dönemlerde üçüncü tercihim
Trakya Tıp Fakültesi,
dördüncü tercihim Yıldız Teknik
Matematik bölümüydü.
Bizim zamanımızda alınabilecek maksimum
puan 520 civarıydı.
Ben 494 puan alarak aslında 405 puanlı
Trakya Tıp Fakültesi’ne değil,
490 küsurluk YTÜ’ye yerleştim.
Hatta o dönemlerde YÖK’e
itirazlarda bulunmama dair
o zaman gittiğim dershaneden
ve arkadaşlarımdan baskı gördüm
ama benim bir daha üniversite sınavıyla
ya da YÖK ile uğraşacak gücüm yoktu.
Bunu okuyacağım artık dedim.
Matematik bölümüne ilk girdiğim gün
herhalde hayatımın en komik günlerinden
bir tanesiydi.
60 kişi birbirini tanımayan, farklı
noktalardan gelen ve okuduğumuz şeyi bize
anlatılan şeyi kesinlikle anlamayan
60 kişi yaklaşık 2 ay harcadıktan sonra
ne kadar tuhaf, hiçbir hocanın
söylediği hiçbir şeyi anlamıyoruz.
Sanki, ya biz Fransızız, ya onlar Fransız.
Ortada bir tercüman yok ve bizler bize
anlatılanlar konusunda
kalem dahi oynatamıyoruz.
2 ayın sonunda bu arada 60 kişinin tamamı
aynı sıkıntıyı çekiyoruz.
Dedik ki bu böyle olmayacak.
Hani geri dönüp üniversiteye de
hazırlanamayacağız.
Çünkü biz çift dönemin çift sınav
dönemi öğrencileriyiz, işte hem ÖSS var
hem ÖYS var, ikisiyle aynı anda uğraşmak
gerçekten hiç akıl alır değil.
Ne yapalım üst sınıflardan birine soralım.
Niye biz bunu yaşıyoruz?
Çok mu aptalız, çok mu problemliyiz acaba?
Yakaladık birkaç kişiyi, dedik:
“Ya, biz hiçbir şey anlamıyoruz.”
Dinlediklerimizi kelimesi kelimesine
yazacağız ama yazamıyoruz bile.
Önce bir gülümsedi yakaladığımız arkadaş
Biraz daha sabret.
Biraz daha sabredin, 15-20 gün
daha sabredin.
Bir sabah kalktığınızda her şey sizin
için berraklaşacak ve anlamadığınızı
zannettiğiniz her şeyi anlamaya
başlayacaksınız.
Aslında çok tuhaf gelmişti.
Kimsenin elinde sihirli değnek falan yok.
2 aydır anlamadığımız şeyi
nasıl iki hafta sonra bir sabah
kalkacağız ve anlayacağız?
Ama gerçekten de söylediği gibi oldu.
Yaklaşık 2 hafta sonra sanki biri
elimde toz beziyle beynimizdeki
bütün o karanlık noktaları silmiş,
temizlemiş ve biz her şeyi anlar,
teorem ispatlar hale gelmiştik.
Burada birinci nokta beyin zorlanmaya
alışkın bir organ ve biz belli bir
eşik değerine kadar onu zorlandığımızda
hiç yapamayacağımızı
ve asla başaramayacağımızı düşündüğümüz
yerde umutsuzluğa kapılmaz.
Yapamayacağım, yapamıyorum sözcüklerinin
ardına sığınmazsak eşik değerini aşan
beynimiz kendini adapte ediyor.
Çünkü insan adaptasyon yeteneği
yüksek canlılardan bir tanesi.
60 kişinin girdiği Yıldız Teknik Matematik
bölümü her sene 2 ya da 3 mezun
vermesiyle övünür.
Biz o sene 55 kişi mezun olduk.
Şu an herkes dünyanın dört bir tarafında
çok kıymetli yerlerde çok kıymetli
işlerle uğraşıyor.
Üniversiteden mezun olduktan sonra ilk
yüzüme çarpan duvar
kadından matematikçi olmaz ifadesiydi.
Bunu bana söyleyen yöneticime onu
çok yakın zamanda
koltuğundan edebileceğini söylemiştim.
Ve kısa süre sonra da bu gerçekleşti.
Çünkü önünüze konulan tabuları, toplumsal
dayatmaları
kabul etmek zorunda değilsiniz.
O dayatmaların dayandığı bir mantık,
matematiksel mantık yoksa geçmişten gelen
öğrenilenlerle sizi yönlendiriyorlarsa
lütfen dikkate almayın.
Kısa bir süre sonra daha Facebook’un bile
olmadığı bir dünyada 2-3 arkadaşla
birlikte veri analiz ederek şirketlere
ürün satmaya karar verdik.
Tabii ilk kapısını çaldığımız şirket
gülmekten yerlere yattı.
“Benim bu kadar yıllık deneyimim var,
sen topladığın verilerle bana neyi
üretmem gerektiğini, nerede satmam
gerektiğini mi anlatacaksın?”
Biraz zorlandık.
Eğitim camiasına girdik.
Fena da gitmiyorduk.
O dönemde aslında yeni başlayan bir
start-up’ın ortağı haline gelmiştim.
Hayatta muhakkak risk alın ve aldığınız
risklerle öylesine düşün ki
hiç kalkmayacakmışçasına düşün
ve kalkmayı başarın.
Çünkü bu yaşadığınız travma hayatta bir
daha hiçbir şeyin sizi yıkamayacağını
gösterir ve vazgeçtiniz şeyler için
yeniden başlayabilme enerjiniz
olduğunu unutmayın.
Şirket çok başarılı bir noktaya gelmişti.
2009 sabahı annemin geçirdiği krizle
karşılaştım ve onu kaybetme tehlikesiyle
karşı karşıya kaldığım için şirketteki
bütün hisselerini devrettim.
O benim tek annemdi
ve ona bakmaya karar verdim.
Bu arada da yarım bıraktığım bir
yükseklisans vardı ama kariyer planlarım
tamamıyla altüst olmuştu.
Olsun, sağlıklıysam, düşünebiliyorsam,
enerjim varsa ve hayata dair
yapabileceklerimizden umutluysam
her zaman yeniden, her zaman
sıfırdan başlayabilirsiniz.
Çünkü sıfırdan sonrası bir, birden
sonrası on, ondan sonrası yüz.
İstanbul Üniversitesi'nde akademisyenlik
teklifi aldım.
Akademisyenliği 7 yıl boyunca İstanbul
Üniversitesi’nde devam ettirdim.
O dönemde çok çeşitli alanlarda örneğin
çocuk suçlularına yönelik matematiksel
modelleme projeleri yaptım ya da
2016 yılında üstün yetenekli sporcuların
tespit edilebilmesi ve giyilebilir cihaz
tasarımı patentleri gerçekleştirdik
çok güzel bir ekiple.
Yani dünyanın şu anda sporda
yapay zekaya kavuştuğu bir dönemde
2016′da bunların patentlerini sahiptim
Üstelik de spordan anlamam.
Takım da tutmuyorum.
Bu hayat hikayesi 7 yıllık İstanbul
Üniversitesi'ni sonlandırmaya karar
verdiğim gün tekrar bir dönüm
noktasına girdim.
Sosyal biri değilim, maalesef hayat bana
o konuda çok adil davranmadı.
Çok destekleyici bir anne babam olmadığı
için aslında kitaplardan başka
kardeşlerimden başka çok fazla
bir dünyam olamadı.
Ama muhakkak benim yaptığımı yapmayın.
Bir hobi edinin ve çalamıyor olsanız bile
muhakkak iki elle çalınabilecek
bir müzik aleti çalın.
Çünkü beyninizin her iki yarım küresini de
aktive edeceği için
öğrenme süreçlerinizi geliştirecek.
İstanbul Üniversitesi’nden
ayrılmaya karar verdiğim gün
herkes bana şunu söyledi.
Çok büyük bir aptallık yapıyorsun.
Bu arada ayrılma hikayem de şöyle;
bir pazartesi sabahı kalktım.
Aynı şey değildir.
Çünkü işin benim hobimdir.
Severek yaparım.
İşimi hala seviyorsam kurumunu değiştirme
vakti gelmiştir dedim.
O pazartesi günü çeşitli üniversitelerin
rektörleri ile görüştüm.
Akşam bir kağıda, lütfen bu da bir kırılma
noktası unutmayın,
bir kağıda benim için neyin
önemli olduğunu çıkardım.
Alt alta yazdım.
Yanlarına ne kadar önemli olduğuna
dair sayılar verdim.
Sonra bu sayıları kapağı kapatıp her
üniversite için yol, maaş, kaç puan diye
puanlar verdim.
Sonrasında o sayıların çarpıp topladım.
En nihayetinde bir üniversitenin sayısal
değeri çok büyük çıktı.
Salı günü istifamı verdim.
Çarşamba günü eşyalarımı topladım.
Perşembe günü o üniversitede başladım.
Dolayısıyla risk alın.
Risk alabilmek sizi güçlü kılar.
Ama bu riski alırken duygusal riskler
üzerine değil
mümkünse ayakları yere basan şekilde
hareket edin.
Sonrasında Amerika macerası başladı.
Emin olun hayatımın en zor deneyimlerinden
bir tanesiydi.
Yurtdışına çıkacaksınız
lütfen bunu erken yaşlarda yapın.
Belli bir yaştan sonra emin olun.
Erken yaşlarda yapmak, bazı alışkanlıkları
kazanmamanız konusunda
size yardımcı olacaktır.
Amerika’ya ilk gittiğimde o zaman
Elektrik Elektronik ve Bilgisayar
Mühendisliği bölümündeydim.
İlk 19 gün kendimden nefret ettim
ve bir köşe koltuğunda
battaniyenin altında oturdum.
Çünkü ben Akdeniz insanıyım.
Benim için sıcak hava 23 derecedir.
Onlar için sıcak hava 10 dereceydi.
Dolayısıyla bu 10 derecede hayata
tutunmaya çalışıyorsunuz, götürdüğünüz
her şey yazlık kıyafet.
Mutsuzsunuz, yemekleri size benzemiyor.
Kültürleri size benzemiyor.
19 günün sonunda yapacak bir şey yok.
“Geri dönmeyeceksin o zaman alış bakalım”
dedim.
Benden önce gitmiş olan arkadaşlarımla
konuştuğumda “19 gün mü sürdü sadece?
Biz 40 gün uğraştık.
40 gün sızlandık.
40 gün geri dönmek istedik.
Sen yine çok şanslıymışsın”, dediler.
O sene dönerken bir hocam benden
bir MIT bardağı almamı istedi.
Sevdiğim bir hatıra türüdür.
Kendi kendime bir
alsam mı diye düşündüm.
Sonra dedim ki gitmediğim üniversitenin
niye bardağını alayım ki?
Belki bir gün, bu deneyimin o gün
kabul olacağını bilemeyiz.
2019 yılının başında MIT’nin
açtığı bir sınava girdim.
Ama sınava girerken aynen şu moddaydım:
“Beni mi alacaklar?”
ama  elimden geleni yaptım.
Hatta beni almayacaklarına
o kadar emindim ki
şu anki üniversitem İstinye Üniversitesi
ile anlaşma imzaladım
ve beni aldılar.
MIT apayrı bir maceraydı.
Orada olmak, ikinci defa Amerika’ya gitmek
yeni bir kültüre yeniden adapte
olmak çok zor gelmedi.
Fakat yurt dışında senelerce yalnız
ve ailenizden yalnız yaşayınca
Hayatta hiçbir şeyin ve hiç kimsenin
sizi yıkamayacağını öğreniyorsunuz.
Çünkü o ilk gittiğinizde o kadar dibe
vuruyorsunuz ki  yukarıdan başka gidecek
yer olmadığını keşfediyorsunuz.
Döndükten sonra
Türkiye’de özellikle yapay zeka alanında
çalışmalar yapmaya başladım
ve henüz daha geleceğin meslekleri konusu
konuşulmazken
2019'da radikal bir kararla meslektaşımla
birlikte Geleceğin Meslekleri
kitabını yazdık.
Başta akademi camiası olmak üzere
pek çok insan tepki gösterdi.
“Olur mu böyle saçma sapan şey” dediler.
Hayatım.
Bunların ilginç cümleleri
ezip geçmek oldu.
Bunları ezip geçerken hiç
yaralanmadım mı?
Evet, çok üzüldüğüm çok yaralandığım
pek çok noktalar oldu ama hayatta
her zaman düştüğünüzde
kalkabileceğinizi biliyorsunuz.
Hiçbir şey zor değildir.
Sadece üzerine yeterli derecede vakit
ayırmadığımız şeyler vardır.
Eğer bir şey size çok zor geliyorsa,
lütfen anne ve babalarınıza dönüp
okuma yazmayı nasıl öğrendiğinizi size
hatırlatmalarını isteyin
ya da çarpım tablosunu nasıl
ezberlediğinizi...
Bunlar o dönemin o zaman yaşadıklarınızın
en büyük zorluklarıydı.
Şimdi sizin için son derece basitler.
Aslında zor gelen her şey bir daha tekrar
edeceğim, üzerinde yeterli derecede vakit
ayırmadıklarımız, ayıramadıklarımız,
kendimizden vazgeçişlerimiz.
Hocam ne kadar başarılı bir
hayat hikayesi anlattın.
Hiç mi başarısızlıkların yok?
Şu zamana kadar 10-15 yurtiçi ve yurtdışı
başarılı projeyi kapatmışsam
122 adet ret ve başarısız projem var.
Hepsini birbirinden daha çok seviyorum.
Çünkü bana en çok şey, öğreten
başarısızlıklarım oldu.
Başarılarınızla bir şey öğrenemezsiniz.
Başarılarınız sadece sizin kendinize
olan güveninizi bir kat daha
jilet gibi hale getirir.
Ama başarısızlıklarınız öyle mi?
Verdikleri dersleri asla unutamazsınız.
Verdikleri dersleri unutmadığınız
gibi nasıl bir daha aynı
hataya düşmeyeceğini öğrenirsiniz.
Bütün hayallerimi gerçekleştirdim mi ?
Tabii ki hayır.
Hayal kırıklıkları insanlar içindir.
Hayal kırıklığı yaşadığınızda
kırıklıklarını yatıştırmaya çalışmayın.
Yeni hayaller kurup yeni hayaller
kurabilecek güce sahipseniz
ve bir kere şundan emin olun.
Eğer bir hayaliniz için elinizden
gelen her şeyi yaptıysanız
ama buna rağmen gerçekleşmiyorsa
Belki de yenisini kurmalısınız,
bırakıp gitmeyi bilmelisiniz.
Hani şu lise duvarlarına yazdığımız meşhur
laf var “Bırak gitsin, dönerse senindir
dönmezse zaten hiç senin olmamıştır.”
Hayallerimiz de böyle.
Yeterli derecede çaba sarf ettiğimizde
bir gün onlara ulaşabiliyorsak
zaten bizimdir.
Ulaşamadığımız da zaten bizim olmamıştır.
Hayal kırıklıklarım, başarısızlıklarım
hayatta en çok sevdiklerim,
en çok gurur duyduklarım.
Kimisi size, başarısız olacaksınız
risk alamayacaksınız diye bir şeyler
söylerse üzerinde durmayın.
Eğer bir şekilde devam edebiliyorsak,
öğrenebiliyorsak, ilerleyebiliyorsak
merak ediyorsak, hayal kırıklıkları
en güzelleri,
başarısızlıklar en güzelleri,
riskler en güzelleri.
Benim hayat hikayemde kimsenin risk
almadığı , start-up’lardan bahsetmediği
bir dönemde risk almak
ve start-up kurmak vardı.
Şimdi de akademisyenlik var.
En çok sevdiğim unvanım doktor unvanı.
Çünkü o unvanı alabilmek için 1-1,5 ay
bir ofis masasında yatmak
zorunda kaldım.
Yani dönüp baktığınızda bütün o anlatılan
süslü ve parıltılı hikayelerin arkasında
ciddi anlamda ya bir Picasso tablosu gibi
kargacık burgacık, eciş bücüş hayatlar
ya da çok büyük dramlar var.
Hayat hiç kimseye adil değil.
Baştaki noktaya geri dönelim.
Bu adaletsizliğin içerisinde hepimiz
kendimiz tırmalamak,
hepimiz kendimiz ilerlemek zorundayız.
Bu adaletsizlik ailemizden gelebilir.
Mesleğimizden gelebilir.
İşimizden gelebilir.
Önce kendinizle barışın, önce ne olursa
olsun devam edebileceğinizi,
düşseniz de kalkabileceğinize inanın.
Her şey insanlar için. Teşekkür ederim.